en plus longtemps c'est à dire que
chaque fois qu'on va voir un policier
s'annonce mal enfin c'est la tête 12 3 %
d'aidés des policiers plus ta découvre
partout aujourd'hui jcb ne tient pas ce
genre d'une à propos ici d'ailleurs j'ai
peut-être peut-être oui bien sûr c'est
possible alors à mal à mal est ce que
pour vous faut interdire l'entrée de la
police dans les quartiers où est ce que
c'est une mesure trop extrêmes alors je
peux comprendre ça me reyes quand il
s'exprime sur sur le alors c'est ça mais
l'idée est qu'il y en a parlé lors de ce
rassemblement
voilà et c'est sa série qui a fait
énormément parler quand on vous dit
c'est ce que vous trouvez c'est trop
voilà c'est trop extrême moi ce que vous
dites oui je comprends oui je comprends
puisque la situation est telle
aujourd'hui dans les quartiers que quand
les policiers interviennent c'est de
façon violente
on le voit bien qu'il n'ya pas le même
traitement quand il s'agit des quartiers
qu'ailleurs
donc nous ce qu'on a envie c'est que
quand elle intervient cette police
quelle qu'elles interviennent dans le
cadre légal et qu'elles ne dépassent pas
le cadre légal au bout simplement et
voulait quand même mais qu'elle
intervienne qu'elle ne soit pas violente
c'est à dire on le voit bien dans le
comportement de certains policiers qui
viennent dans les quartiers on voit bien
qu'ils sont là pour venir casser des
gens alors votre ferme amine ben tout ce
qui a été abattu d'une balle dans le dos
2012 lors d'une course poursuite à
noisy-le-sec
oui donc vous vous n'êtes pas aussi
extrême vous dites ils viennent mais
vous voulez que voilà qu'il y ait que ce
qu'il soit la plus juste pose de ce que
dans si je dois voilà si je dois résumer
votre votre pensée vous dit pas il doit
plus y dort plus du tout venir dans les
banlieues dans l'état actuel et le
comportement qu'elle a cette police
je suis d'accord avec samir yes mais
elle doit intervenir dans le cadre légal
et pas dépasser le cadre légal faire
subir de la violence à deux jeunes
hommes dans les quartiers juste hier
j'ai encore un papa qui m'a appelé qui
me dit à bagneux ça s'est passé à
bagneux son fils a eu peur il a couru
ils étaient 3,4 gamin il s'est retrouvé
à ressortir du commissariat tuméfié il a
14 ans pourquoi il a eu peur de quoi
voilà il a eu peur il a couru parce que
c'est un policier qui qu'on surnomme
qu'on surnomme hitler qui est bien connu
pour passer à tabac deux jeunes garçons
et il en a subi les conséquences
donc ce jeune garçon il avait rien fait
son papa m'a appelé qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
donc voilà c'est ça la la problématique
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
comment se comporte comment ces
policiers se comportent et quelles
solutions
on doit trouver pour que ces policiers
soient soit mis de côté et que qui
qu'ils soient
la culture c'est comprenez vous ce
qu'ils appellent la police à ne plus
rentrer dans les quartiers gens c'est
bien on chante on vous dit non
moi je pense que c'est une mauvaise idée
parce que justement ces quartiers
réputés difficiles réputé sensible ce
sont des endroits où justement on a
besoin de sécurité
en revanche ses propos ce qui démontre
c'est que on a un vrai problème en
france avec l'image de la police la
police et une sale image et quand on lit
ça on a l'impression que la police c'est
un parti politique c'est un groupement
idéologique que les policiers sont
racistes c'est pas vrai les policiers et
des hommes et des femmes qui font un
métier très important déjà qui essaie de
bien faire leur métier
par contre pensent qu'il faut faire un
vrai travail sur l'image de la police ça
va pas qu'on dise qu effectivement j'ai
lu c'est aussi que soi-disant 80% des
policiers sont racistes je pense que
c'est pas vrai je pense que c'est
n'importe quoi
alors il ya des gens qui réagissent sur
les réseaux sociaux ayant qui dit dans
les quartiers il ya aussi des familles
qui sont bien contentes de voir que
dallas exact isabelle pense que la pire
chose qui pourrait arriver à ces
quartiers et aux centaines d'habitants
qui sont dans ces cartes et c'est que
précisément la police n'y est plus parce
que là il serait dans un sentiment
d'insécurité absolue tant qu il faille
renouer un dialogue ça je vous comprends
très bien là dessus mais en revanche
dire qu'il faut que ces gens là sont des
dangers dans les cités c'est sûr il
suffit d'ailleurs ermo des marques
dunkerque vous vous en pensez quoi de ce
qu'ils disent que la police ne doit plus
rentrer dans les quartiers sensibles
je rappelle que oui vous êtes policier
oui tout à fait moi j'en pense que s'il
n'y a pas de contrôle social exercé par
une police républicaine il sera exercée
par des caïds de cités et je pense qu'il
vaut mieux être contrôlé par des
policiers qui si jamais ils dérivent
doivent rendre compte de leurs actes
devant une institution qui est dit gpn
plutôt qu'être livré aux mains de caïds
qui se sont dans le trafic de drogue
non je suis pas gérer les quartiers
sensibles en fait fait j'ai beaucoup
travaillé dans les quartiers sensibles
il faut savoir qu'à une économie
parallèle qui est complètement implantée
cette économie parallèle elle génère du
travail génère de l'argent il ya aussi
qu'il ya plein de gens qui sont très
très heureux de vivre dans ces quartiers
voilà est qui qui est avec qui et autres
qui ça se passe très très bien
je vous le dis moi je vois plein de
choses au sziget qui aide qui aide
énormément des familles parce que tout
le monde s'en plaint on dit que c'est
des ghettos on dit que ce sont des gens
qu'elles sont abandonnés